Valentina tavloy gets emotional when she
remembers what happened here in February
never expected
I was sitting in front of the window
when the explosion threw me to the floor
I don't remember much after then but
after that I fled to the forest
it was April before she returns to pick
up the pieces zalisia her Village
Northeast of Kiev saw Fierce fighting as
Russian troops tried and failed to take
Ukraine's Capital
can you imagine all the roof was damaged
the windows the doors thank God the
walls were still standing and the Red
Cross helped us to repair the roof but
there are people who lost everything
the estimated cost of rebuilding Ukraine
keeps spiraling upwards in September the
World Bank said it was 350 billion
dollars a month ago Ukraine's government
guessed 750 billion now president
zielinski is saying one trillion
non-governmental organizations like the
international Committee of the Red Cross
have some money to help but it's
Millions not billions of course we can't
help all the people here so we focus on
the most vulnerable population here so
it's a big families with many children
and people with a low income mostly
elderly people and also people with
disabilities
their cash handouts can be used for
whatever repairs are most pressing but
snow and ice have brought most building
work to a standstill so new Registries
like zineda might have to wait until
spring winter is not an abstract concept
particularly during wartime whereas in
the warmer months you'd probably be okay
living in a building like this with
blown out windows or a damaged roof when
the temperature plummets such conditions
really take their toll
metal cabins how some whose homes are
uninhabitable but they're Mains powered
so in the frequent blackouts they
quickly become refrigerators Valentina
is trying to stay positive
it could be worse compared to our boys
in the trenches they're freezing I keep
active during the day but last night it
was a bit scary when the lights went off
I put on my hat my hood the electricity
was off from one until nine pm
but winter has only just begun it's
going to feel like a very very long one
indeed Rory challenge now to zero key of
reason